as we look around the united states we
often think has a better country ever
been led by worse people
probably not
so in our spare time we've looked around
the world we try from time to time to
bring leaders on this show from other
countries who actually care about their
people that's we went to hungary this
summer to talk to victor orban
but he's not the only one
when we spoke to orban he mentioned
other countries in central europe that
have defended their populations
against international interference and
one of the countries he mentioned was
poland
in the last few nights in budapest i've
run into a number of americans who have
come here because they want to be around
people who agree with them who agree
with you do you see budapest as
as a kind of
capital of this kind of thinking
the capital of that kind of thinking or
one of the capitals because the other
central european countries are also very
competitive and producing very nice
ideas and
organizing that kind of communities of
conservative and
and christian democrats
thinkers as we do
andre duda is the president of poland
and we're honored to be joined by him
right now mr president thank you so much
for joining us we we know that you're
watching what's happening in the united
states and you're watching this massive
flow of migrants over our border it will
total over a million just this year
something very similar happened to
europe in 2015 the eu pressured poland
and other nations in central europe to
accept
and poland fought back tell us why you
did that
the answer is very simple we did not
agree back then in 2015 to the so-called
quota system which was proposed by some
of the eu member states which means that
every single country would have to
accept a given number of migrants and we
give a very clear answer to that whoever
wants to come to poland whoever is
looking for help assistance especially
refugees who are looking for shelter
because they are threatened by war
persecuted in their own countries if
they want to come to poland we want them
to stay in poland live in poland
well to accept such a person and to help
them we did not agree to relocate poland
people by force
we do not agree to keep these people in
prison if these people did not want to
stay in poland they would want to leave
and we're not going to make anybody stay
we're not going to keep anybody against
their will the american president joe
biden
before he became president described
poland as unfree as an authoritarian
place
how have your dealings with the bidet
administration been since he's become
president
what you just said is indeed very
regrettable thing because there are a
lot of lies spread about poland in the
first and foremost what some
representatives of the polish opposition
are saying about the current polish
government is totally untrue
and the best proof of that is in the
fact that the incumbent government has
won the election they won the election
back in 2019.
it simply said people are happy with
their government right now they think
that this government cares for their
interests that this government keeps
electoral promises and this is why they
were re-elected but of course some
representatives of the opposition are
really furious because they are not able
to win elections as i said they lost
twice in a row they also lost the
presidential election so because of that
they are slandering the current
political campaign
let me reiterate fortunately it is the
people who choose
finally let me ask you about poland's
family policy
so poland from the outside appears to
have decided to help encourage polish
couples to have children please tell us
what you're doing and why you've done it
the constitution stipulates that
marriage it says a union of a man and a
woman and family are protected by the
government in a special way so the first
time since 1989 we have embarked upon a
very resolute and vast pro-family action
and when i was running for president
back in 2015 i also made a pledge and i
said that we would start a pro family
policy we offered we actually announced
myself during the campaign and later i
was joined by my colleagues who were
also running for the parliamentary
election so we pledged that we would
introduce a program by the name of 500
plus it is a welfare program for
families in its initial version we were
testing actually we decided that
starting from the second child in a
family parents of every child monthly to
receive 500 slotties
some of 130 dollars a kind of welfare
for many from the state and raising
children this program was revolutionized
in poland i think nobody can imagine not
to have the 500 plus program in poland
that was the best thing definitely the
best social program that we have been
able to introduce but to me a politician
speaking openly i consider myself to be
rather conservative and i actually
was always frank about my views i'm a
christian i'm a practicing christian i
pray i'm not ashamed of that whatsoever
and to me the value of family is
priceless i do support families i'm
pro-life i defend life i believe that
life is sacred
i believe it should be guarded and
families have to be supported as strong
as they can because family is the
foundation of every nation everything is
based on family therefore the support
with which we offer families for the
political perspective from my personal
perspective is key importance we also
have used other programs supporting
families we support parents with their
child starting schools with programs
dubbed 300 slotties so we pay 300
slotties to the parents of every child
going to school to buy a set of books a
rust set and pens pencils stationary
whatever the child needs starting school
that is a very difficult moment when the
school year begins we know that families
have to spend more money so it turned
out that 300 slotties is important for
the families and it also contributes
quite big support on top of the 500 plus
which every family gets per child
it's inspiring to hear that i wish we
had it mr president thank you for
sitting down and talking to us tonight
we appreciate it's good to see you
thank you very much and my best
greetings to you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else